hey guys what's up
we have been thinking a lot about
transformers lately and so we made this
video about the 20 biggest transformers
from Michael Bay life action movies we
know that there are quite a few size
comparison videos about transformers but
we will do it differently and with
explanations on these different metallic
life forms in this list Optimus Prime
did not even make it to the cut alone
and had to be in a combined form with
Jetfire to be included and now you know
the magnitude of such a comparison also
the bet driller transform of shockwave
never made it to any of the other videos
and we will bring justice to it by
putting it here just a hint its way up
the scale but before you continue on
with the video do you like share and
subscribe for more related content and
check out our channel as we have more
than 80 other videos oh yes mash the
notification bell for regular updates
anyway here are the 20 biggest
transformers from live-action movies
number 20 Megatron
Megatron aka Galvatron is the leader of
the Decepticons and as the main
antagonist of the first film the
secondary antagonist in the next two
films the tertiary antagonists in the
fourth while reborn as Galvatron and
prior to the events of the movies
Megatron came across the Fallen who
corrupted him and convinced him that the
Allspark should be his and therefore
became a tyrannical ruler throughout the
movie series his design differs but his
height remains at 35 feet or 10 point 7
meters number 19 shockwave shockwave was
a peerless Decepticon scientist with
deadly efficiency and a co devotion to
logic he was also one of the deadliest
Decepticon assassins that Megatron has
at his disposal he was said by some to
be the only Decepticon who could defeat
Megatron in combat shockwave is a
killing machine like few others one of
the very few who could rival Megatron in
Michael Bay movies shockwave is stated
to be over 40 feet tall are almost 12.2
meters
number 18 Optimus Prime
slash Jetfire Optimus Prime is the
leader of the Autobots long ago he was
the humble leader of Cybertron's science
division we studied the Allspark when
Megatron was corrupted by the Fallen
Optimus discovered that he was the last
of the dynasty of the primes hidden away
when the Fallen destroyed their lineage
so he became the leader of the Autobots
alone
Optimus is only 28 feet tall but
combined with Jetfire in revenge of the
Fallen he stands at 40 feet tall of
twelve point two meters number 17 the
original Prime's the primes are an
ancient line of ancestors of the
Transformers that rule over a vast
empire in the galaxy these beings could
not transform but they and their
transforming descendants possess powers
beyond that of the average Cybertronian
the dynasty ruled Cybertron and
protected the Allspark replenishing it
with the energy harvested from stars the
original Prime's were not named in the
movie series but were on the same
stature as the Fallen being in between
40 and 45 feet tall
number 16 infernicus infernicus was a
powerful semi robotic demon combiner
that is formed from the infernal cones
the bloodthirsty warriors of Quintessa
when Quintessa captured Optimus Prime in
fur the curse was fully combined and
grabbed Prime's head so as to face him
towards Quintessa in the final battle
megatron commanded the infant accounts
ordering them to combine into infernicus
he was later killed by Optimus Prime it
was later stated that infernicus stood
at 42 feet tall or almost 13 metres
number 15 the Fallen the Fallen is a
fictional robot supervillain in a
Transformers Robot superhero franchise
according to Hasbro he was formerly
known as Megatron as prime megatronus
was one of the original 13 primes
created by Primus and a founder of the
Decepticons in many storylines in
revenge of the Fallen he was seen after
the matrix and about to end humanity by
draining the sun's power until he was
defeated by Optimus Prime the official
height of the Fallen is 13 metres or 42
feet tall
number fourteen scrapper scrapper is a
Constructicons scout that transforms
into a front load shovel when combined
with his fellow construct cons he
becomes the right arm of Devastator he
may also share a name with another robot
of the same model who saw action in the
Battle of Egypt or yet a third one who
saw action in the Battle of Chicago
while standing at his two legs scrapper
is 45 feet tall all thirteen point seven
meters in height
number 13 Jetfire Jetfire is the name of
several fictional characters from the
Transformers franchise he is almost
always depicted as an Autobot with
flight capabilities as a jet or a Space
Shuttle as an alternate mode but in the
movies he was seen as an aging and
miserable old Decepticon who changed
sites with the Autobots this transformer
could shape-shift into an sr-71
blackbird which is a very large air
vehicle and that is why in his normal
form he stands at 50 feet tall or
fifteen point two meters in height
number 12 grind or grinder was a massive
hulking Decepticon who like most other
Decepticons was loyal to Megatron he was
a master strategist and a close combat
specialist rind or hat can project his
opponent's next move before they know it
themselves it has reached a point where
it is less planning and more instinct on
his part but even so he was still
defeated by Optimus Prime in a
three-on-one battle alongside Megatron
and Starscream in the movie he is around
50 feet tall of 15 point 2 meters number
11 strafe strafe was among the Dinobots
freed from lockdown ship and
subsequently yielded to Optimus Prime's
command during the battle in Hong Kong
strafe aided bumblebee as he battled
stinger the two fought on straights back
until stinger was defeated and strength
got to munch on stingers head strafe
transforms into a gigantic two-headed
fire-breathing metal dragon light
pterosaur
but in his normal form strafe was 57
feet tall and the smallest of the
Dinobots
number ten long haul long hauls body
type was one of the early Constructicons
drones used to build star harvesters one
of the long haul joint the Fallen
original Decepticons it was him who
discovered humans on earth remarking
there were number of these breakable
creatures out there long haul deserved
as the Decepticons ground-based heavy
hitter with his long-range charged
grenades and flamethrower he stands at
65 feet tall or almost 20 meters number
nine dragon storm dragon storm is a
beastly three-headed dragon mighty just
a form of the legendary 12th Garden
Knights who post Quintessa in four and
84 AD the Knights form dragon storm at
man's behest to wipe out the Saxons
winning the battle for Camelot the 12th
garden Knights were at alesis tall or
taller than Optimus Prime but when
combined into dragon storm the mighty
metallic B stands twice as tall at least
more than 70 feet tall with a wingspan
of around 300 feet or more than 90
metres wide
number 8 slug slug was another one among
the Dinobots trap aboard knockdowns ship
until the autobots detached that section
for their own use slug was among the
Dinobots hiding out with the other
Autobots in gates jamia he transforms
into a gigantic Triceratops and later in
the movie when their refuge was
discovered he joined Grimlock and
bursting from the ground to attack a
convoy of TRF vehicles sloth was big in
a strife at 71 feet tall or 20 1.6
meters number 7 demolisher the marshal
was a very large Constructicons
transformer that was seen in the opening
scenes of The Revenge of the Fallen he
was the one predicting that the Fallen
shall rise again this transformer was
hiding in Shanghai and was hunted down
by the Autobots and their human allies
as a military expert he is no doubt one
of the most valued member of the
Decepticon army the militia was almost
identical to scavenger and it was stated
to be 74 feet tall or 20 2.5 meters
number six scavenger scavenger was
another large construct card and
transformed into a Tareq's oh and key
are each for her excavator when combined
with his fellow construct cons he forms
part of the upper torso of Devastator
during the climactic battle in egypt
between the orbits their human allies
and Follis Decepticons scavenger
appeared in a quarry with the other
construct cards before merging into
Devastator he is 75 feet tall or twenty
two point eight meters in height number
five Grimlock Grimlock is a Dinobot with
a rather rough and tough attitude one of
the most powerful warriors alive his
general approach to a problem is to
smash it first worry about the specifics
later
Grimlock was a prisoner aboard lockdown
ship until the autobots detached that
section and flew it to China he was then
freed and battled with Optimus Prime and
he'll finally agree to help the Autobots
against lockdown and the other
Decepticons he is 84 feet tall or twenty
five point six meters number four scorn
scorn is an Autobot Dinobot from the age
of extinction portion of the live-action
film series
continuty family scorn is what happens
when you combine a destructive war
machine with an ancient prehistoric
predator he can take the form of what
appears to be a Spinosaurus although he
is the demolitions expert Scott is the
least intelligent of the Dinobots his
robot mode resembles a knight with the
tail forming a powerful spear scorn is
87 feet tall or twenty six point five
meters number three Devastator
Devastator is an immensely powerful
warrior and in the sense that the
combination of the construct cons merge
into a being is impressive
whether he's formed from six to nine
constructicon devastator is a giant
among Giants he is in fact so huge and
his body simply cannot support itself
when carrying his weight
upright forcing him to lumber on all
fours Devastator is named after
Cybertron's understandable and
terrifyingly destructive Devastator wins
in the revenge of the Fallen he stated
to be a hundred and eight feet tall or
33 meters
number two driller the largest
subterranean life-form native to
Cybertron drillers are not to be taken
lightly enormous multi-tentacled B is
capable of burrowing through the ground
all through buildings with ease
they are capable of great destruction
and garnish on any scale naturally all
these qualities have endeared them to
shockwave who keeps one as a pet and a
personal transport according to the
special effects team the driller is the
length of three football fields that
would make it roughly one zero eight
zero feet long or clear at 30 meters
long number one Unicron according to the
Transformers mythos
unicron's origins come from literally
before the dawn of time when he was
created by the one as a representation
of pure chaos along with Unicron his
twin brother Primus was created here
cron is not like other transformers he
is so glad grant Chuen that he can
transform into a mechanical planet
himself in the last night on light
although not seen in his entirety but
only the horns Unicron was said to be
the planet Earth
therefore putting his size at more than
12,000 kilometers so this brings us to
the end of the list and do like share
and subscribe for more of these monster
transformers and guide you content